well I think the best strategy for the
United States and leave the Allies the
United States in this struggle or war on
terrorism moving forward is to make no
huge strategic blunders in the future
Iraq was a huge strategic blunder it
allowed al-qaeda to rally an
organization which was on the ropes
Guantanamo was a huge strategic blunder
Abu Ghraib was a regrettable blunder it
really gave al-qaeda a perfect
recruiting tool in trying to get the
volunteers which are necessary for his
global jihad so do no harm would be a
very good mantra for the next u.s.
president to take on beyond that I think
that the next u.s. president really has
to make us a sort of symbolic break with
past policies the paradigm with which
the u.s. is viewed at the moment is a
very negative one that needs to be
broken by it whoever the next US
candidate to become president is going
to be if george w bush is a very
unpopular figure in the Islamic world
some of that is obviously unfair but the
reality is the president united states
and the united states is viewed very
negatively right now that needs to
change the most important part of that
is for United States to think very
carefully about how it comes up with
foreign policy decisions in the years to
come it really has to put the views of a
billion Muslims around the world in as a
factor in calculating the foreign policy
that it needs to pursue so that these
are very important the things to
consider when you're moving forward
clearly the United States also has to be
seen as really trying for peace between
Israel and Palestine which has been a
very very impor
an issue in the Muslim world it's been
the cause of a lot of anti-americanism
in past years because America rightly or
wrongly is seen as not being even-handed
in that dispute in the last year's and
certainly during the Bush administration
so the president obviously now is making
a push for peace there's an enormous
amount of skepticism in the Arab world
in the Muslim world about his motives I
think the next president really needs to
be able to persuade Muslims around the
world that the United States really is
engaged in an even-handed attempt to
create peace in the Middle East the
Kashmir dispute between India and
Pakistan is another issue which the
United States and the next president
really should get involved with as an
arbiter between Pakistan and India the
Kashmir dispute is also something which
causes radicalization it's an issue
which is destabilizing for Pakistan
which right now is tarah central
unfortunately Kashmir dispute has been
allowed to fester for decades and it's a
it's a dispute where you'll you're
getting generations of jihadists
involved in Pakistan who who sort of
going from the tribal areas the country
to go and fight in that the disputed
territory but in Kashmir so that's
another area United States President
really needs to address moving forward
in an even-handed way those are the
sorts of departures which are very very
important and other the next u.s.
president really has to sort of
concentrate on but but but a lot of it
also will be in terms of rhetoric
there's suddenly the United States had a
sudden interests in the Middle East
which are non-negotiable and which which
which should not be given up but the
next u.s. president really has to engage
in a rhetoric which is going to explain
what the United States is doing the
United States is not a colonial power
there's a great deal amount of suspicion
in the Middle East and beyond the United
States is a colonial power because of
the history of a colonial subjugation of
Western powers and in the region so the
next u.s. president and this is for the
u.s. present this is not for the State
Department it's not a question of public
diplomacy
it's the question of what the united
states president is seen as saying
moving forward